la crème des états unis et de l'europe
c'est de voir la chine et de la russie
pour qu'elle puisse poursuivre sa guerre
en ukraine est-ce que selon vous cet
échange entre reggio byden et si jean
ping pourra ou plutôt contribuera à
dissuader la chaîne à offrir son aide à
la russie bah je pense que oui parce que
y est les etats unis c'est le seul pays
qui peut mettre la pression sur la chine
est à son tour la chaîne c'est le seul
pays qui peut mettre de la pression sur
la russie pour essayer d'en arriver à un
cessez le feu c'est moi je pense que
même s'il semble qu'ils aient eu des des
résultats un peu mitigé aujourd'hui
c'est une discussion importante quand on
veut aussi un peu de mouvement de la
part de la chaîne en notant que si jean
ping a fait allusion au problème
croissant
du côté économique et il a déploré les
sanctions qui selon lui pénalise les
citoyens et en plus à la télévision
chinoise on commence à montrer des
scènes de la guerre c'est donc il ya un
peu de mouvements du côté de la chine
oui parce que pour les chinois en fait
on avait la version reçue les gens
croyaient que c'était une guerre que la
russe menait pour protéger oui il a tué
la chaîne se retrouve dans une position
dans un dealer une position très
difficile parce que juste avant les jeux
olympiques il faut se rappeler que si
jean ping et vladimir poutine ont
entériné un nouveau partenariat
stratégique qui qui vont résister aux
vins et aux marais puis là maintenant la
chine voit que l'état entraînée malgré
elle dans une situation qui est de plus
en plus déplorables et au même moment
elle commence à comprendre que plus la
guerre dure et plus il y aura des
impacts économiques sur l'ordre sur
l'économie mondiale et aussi sur la
chine oui la chaîne qui avait été prévu
que l'armée russe allait éprouver des
difficultés et que le monde aussi se
montrent unis et ferme dans ses
sanctions contre la russie alors est-ce
que s'il ya de quoi mettre à l'épreuve
l'amitié sans limite entre l'est du pays
sans parlier qui avait été annoncé de
façon solennelle à l'ouverture des jeux
de pékin je pense que oui puis prend le
mcs monsieur byden puis-je à passer en
fait tous les leaders étrangers qui on
parle m xi jingping récemment comme le
président à maquereau ou le chancelier
les choses ont dû lui répliqua les
échanges économiques avec l'union
européenne sont beaucoup plus importants
qu'avec la russie on parle de 800
milliards de dollars comparativement à
140 milliards les les échanges aussi
avec les etats-unis sont très importants
et puis monsieur by d'aujourd'hui a été
très explicite si la russie devait saga
s'engager davantage à appuyer la russie
elle pourrait être sujette à des
sanctions très important c'est une année
aussi jean ping a besoin de bonnes
nouvelles de stabilité pour assurer sa
réélection
comme secrétaire général du parti au
congrès du parti qui doit avoir lieu en
octobre cette année oui hier 19 journal
allemand a rapporté que le ministre des
affaires étrangères sergueï lavrov en
route vers pékin aurait fait demi tour
aujourd'hui semble-t-il que la russie
voulait présenter une résolution au
conseil de sécurité mais ne leur ai pas
fait faute d'appui de la chine et de
l'inde alors est ce que ce sont des
signes pour vous qui pourrait annoncer
justement un changement d'attitude chez
eux face à la russie face à cette guerre
mais moi je pense qu'il ya un débat qui
est en cours à pékin parce que il ya
beaucoup de gens qui qui sont inquiets
de la situation qui se sentent un peu
prisonnier de la rhétorique c'est bien
sûr que la chine et la russie ont en
commun de s'opposer aux états unis il
parce que les états le but des états
unis de ces deux-là de contenir ces deux
pays là mais là ils s'aperçoivent aussi
qu'il y a des répercussions et
le problème pour la chine c'est qu'elle
n'est pas habitué
à gérer ce genre de colère parce que
même si elle dit qu'elle est une super
puissance elle ne veut pas jouer leur
rôle que jouent les états unis le rôle
de gendarme du monde et elle ne s'est
pas comme format comment agir et puis je
pense qu'il va falloir l'aider à
articuler une solution à ce conflit et
ce sont les états unis qui pourrait
l'aider à faire quoi par exemple
ben moi je pense que ce sont
les états unis ont sans doute expliquer
la chine que étant donné la dépendance
croissante de la russie envers la chine
parce que tu as toujours avec lui les
échanges économiques
sont pas aussi importants qu'avec le
reste de l'europe pour la russie c'est
un partenaire très important
et puis si la chine mais son poids et
dit il faut faire des compromis mais
elle pourrait mettre de l'avant par
exemple une solution qui consisterait à
établir que l'ukraine va être un état
neutre dont la neutralité pour être
garantie par une mission des
nations-unies et puis bien sûr il reste
l'épineuse question qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec les deux républiques
du donnenbach c'est avec la crimée oui
alors il de son côté l'ukraine ne veux
pas être un état neutre on verra bien
pour la suite des choses fait
intéressant est à souligner aussi
aujourd'hui c'est que la chine a parlé
d' aide humanitaire alors quel message
vettel envoyé par
l'ocde clarations là aussi je pense est
une reconnaissance de la part de la
chine qu'elle a aussi besoin de
l'ukraine parce que l'ukraine était un
fournisseur très importante de blé
donges de maïs et il ya la chaîne se
rend compte que ses approvisionnements
le port est menacée de d'autre part
l'ukraine est un pays très important
pour la grande initiative ainsi jean
ping à la ceinture la route la nouvelle
route de la soie à cause de sa position
géographique et la chine commencent à
passer
les hostilités vont se terminer un jour
qui va falloir aider à reconstruire
d'ukraine et puis elle veut commencer
l'opération la de de se revaloriser
devant l'opinion publique et surtout
devant l'opinion ukrainienne oui
peut-être en terminant spécifié qu on l
oublie peut-être mais un accord
bilatéral avait été signée récemment
entre la chine l'ukraine pour que la
chine investisse massivement dans les
chemins de fer les aéroports les
infrastructures en ukraine oui tout à
fait c'est ça c'est en fait bien sûr
l'ukraine avait reçu c'est cette
promesse et promet un abaissement avec
beaucoup d'enthousiaste et puis ça fait
partie de la vision de ce jumping
d'étendre son influence économique et
politique en asie centrale en europe
centrale et de là à les couvrir le
maximum de pays en europe c'est donc
c'est je pense que la chine commence à
comprendre où sont ses intérêts et
qu'elle va devoir commencer à prendre un
peu de recul par rapport à la russie
merci beaucoup monsieur saint-jacques
d'abord été avec moi ce soir
merci pour l'invitation au revoir